[Musica]
come posso rendermi utile cambiare la
mia piccola realtà o cambiare il mondo
che mai sorta a questa domanda a me
spesso infatti penso che usando le
parole di martin luther king
la domanda più insistente e urgente
della vita e cosa sto facendo per gli
altri l'articolo 1 della dichiarazione
universale dei diritti umani dice tutti
gli esseri umani nascono liberi ed
eguali in dignità e diritti
essi sono dotati di ragione e di
coscienza e devono agire gli uni verso
gli altri in spirito di fratellanza
libertà uguaglianza dignità diritti
ragione coscienza e spirito di
fratellanza
questi sono i valori che traspaiono
dalla dichiarazione universale dei
diritti umani scritta dalle nazioni
unite e ad oggi supportata da quasi
tutti i paesi del mondo
eppure quante persone si sentono in
difesa senza potere o senza libertà e tu
come ti senti cresciamo sapendo un po
dell'uguaglianza come valore concetto o
forse anche diritto dovuto ma è davvero
così la realtà siamo davvero tutti
liberi e da venti gli stessi diritti
come mai invece sembra esserci così
tanta disuguaglianza nel mondo come mai
esistono ancora le caste come mai in più
di 70 paesi del mondo le persone non
sono liberi di amare in quanto
l'omosessualità è considerata un crimine
come mai negli stati uniti le famiglie
bianche anni in media più di sette volte
la ricchezza delle famiglie nera come
mai più di due su tre dei quasi 800
milioni di analfabeti del mondo sono
donne
io oggi sono qui perché sono attivi sta
ormai da dieci anni e faccio attivismo
per i diritti delle donne
oramai trent'anni fa sono nata proprio
qui a reggio emilia la prima metà della
mia vita è stata un'esperienza un po
ovattata diciamo
mondo di confort ma soprattutto perché
mi confrontavo più spesso che non con le
cose molto schon cose persone molto
simili a me quando ho 17 anni invece mi
sono trasferita negli stati uniti e gli
ultimi 13 anni della mia vita li ho
vissuti fra stati uniti asia ed
inghilterra nel corso degli anni però fa
ho viaggiato in più di 50 paesi del
mondo e ho fatto progetti in paesi come
la palestina sudafrica e tantissimi
altri posti
il mio impegno attivismo però sono nati
da un'esperienza personale nel 2013
l'india era un paese infuocato a causa
della violenza di genere poiché nel 2012
era successo uno stupro di gruppo ed
omicidio di una ragazzina giovanissima
mi ricordo ancora come mi sentivo
vedendo i volti delle ragazzine le donne
bruciate dall'acido l'india in paese con
una grossissima disuguaglianza sociale
pressione diciamo socioculturale nei
confronti delle donne
quella realtà così così piena di
disuguaglianza ha tagliato diciamo
profondamente la mia superficie
privilegiata quella rabbia entrata anche
dentro di me ma cosa ho imparato da
tutte queste esperienze all'estero
multiculturali e diciamo da queste
realtà così diverse
ho capito che l'uguaglianza in realtà
non esiste la realtà e la disuguaglianza
gli oramai sui 10 anni che faccio
attivismo e una delle mie prime
esperienze e stata proprio dopo l'india
quando ho fatto partire un impresa
sociale a cui missione era quella di
fare raccolta dati per la sicurezza
geografica per le donne ma adesso vi
voglio raccontare della mia ultima
campagna nel 2019 stavo facendo una
ricerca su google ricerca era al
sinonimi di donna in inglese quindi
women's e.on ems e il risultato che ho
trovato era questa lista molto lunga di
sinonimi dispregiativi quali pezzettino
bagaglio cavalla i tantissimi altri che
non voglio ripetere
inoltre c'erano anche molte frasi di
esempio d'uso estremamente sessiste e
discriminanti
diciamo che la visione totale ea quella
della donna come essere umano inferiore
rispetto all'uomo ma soprattutto anche
come oggetto sessuale qualche ricerca ho
scoperto che questa definizione questa
questa voce del dizionario veniva dal
dizionario di oxford dal famigerato fra
incidere dizionario di oxford e
chirurgicamente la mia reazione era
quella di choc era bianche perché mi
sono chiesto varie volte il perché
diciamo questa fosse la definizione di
donna e dopo qualche mese al loro fatto
partire una petizione su change.org
diciamo senza grandissime aspettative
pensando che forse un'istituzione come
oxford non avrebbe cambiato la sua
definizione ma l'ho fatta a partire nel
giro di pochissimi giorni
questa petizione la quale chiedeva
appunto la il miglioramento della della
definizione di donna ma anche diciamo
aveva un aspetto di inclusività rispetto
alla comunità lgbt questa petizione
appunto stata firmata da nel giro di
qualche mese da migliaia di persone
ventimila persone ma soprattutto è stata
anche supportata da tantissime testate
mediatiche quali il guardian il new york
times il times of india ma anche
repubblica o comunque quotidiano i
reggiani dopo diciamo quasi un anno
oxford a novembre 2020 ha deciso di
cambiare la sua definizione e e ad oggi
sto portando avanti questa battaglia
anche in italia contro treccani
il cambiamento è veramente prossimo e io
e tutte queste persone
queste ad oggi 30 35 mila persone
siamo riusciti a cambiare la definizione
del 50 per cento della popolazione
tramite appunto una semplicissima
petizione
questa è la violazione diritti umani e
di mancata dignità alla quale io ho
reagito
io vorrei aggiunge le tantissime altre
persone che hanno firmato la petizione
ma cos'è allora l'attivismo digitale e
fa per te actionaid descrive gli
attivisti e attiviste come persone che
credono in un futuro migliore
sentono il bisogno di cambiamento e
dedicano il proprio tempo per
realizzarlo l'attivismo digitale è
semplicemente quando usiamo la
tecnologia per far partire questo
cambiamento appunto per creare un futuro
migliore tecnologia che può essere il
tuo telefonino
il tuo computer o appunto i social media
o semplicemente l'internet ma ahimè
attivismo ad oggi è una parola che fa un
po paura che viene vista come una
posizione anarchica di estremismo po
come una militanza
ma questa non è la realtà a perché
appunto gli attivisti e le attiviste
sono semplicemente persone che vogliono
creare un futuro migliore
la petizione on line a proteste di marzo
organizzate tramite i social media ha
raccolte fondi o quello arabo nazioni
interculturali e anche globali che
avvengono tramite la tecnologia il
cambiamento può appunto essere fatto con
la tecnologia è più che altro la
tecnologia può fare da leva per poterlo
accelerare e poter fare in modo che
tutti noi ci uniamo e tutti noi parliamo
di ciò che non va e ci attiviamo per
cambiarlo
e allora come puoi renderti utile essere
parte del cambiamento
questi sono tre modi step numero 1
coinvolgimento personale ovvero un po
come in terapia il primo passo è quello
di capire che c'è un problema per
poterlo poi affrontare quindi informati
prova a guardare ad esempio sui social
media
a seguire certi attivisti a leggere
sulle testate mediatiche cosa sta
succedendo informati un po
dell'ingiustizia
la seconda cosa che puoi fare è la
testimonianza diciamo fai da te come
abbiamo visto in america con il
movimento black climate ad oggi
tutti sappiamo che potere a un
semplicissimo video
quindi se sei tu che subisce
un'ingiustizia o se ad esempio la vedi
per strada
o se o se vedi sui social media un video
ri condiviso di qualcosa di sbagliato
che sta accadendo ri condividilo anche
tu parlane con i tuoi amici con le tue
amiche e diciamo parla appunto di questa
cosa di questa ingiustizia perché è
importantissimo il terzo modo e la
mobilitazione
esistono già tantissime attivisti e
attiviste organizzazioni che stanno
facendo campagna raccolta fondi e
petizioni supporto lì oppure se sei tu
che vi fa sentire una campagna una
petizione una raccolta fondi falla
partire
l'attivismo non ti deve far paura un po
come prova la mia campagna non c'è
l'istituzione che non si possa
affrontare e non c'è un cambiamento che
non possa avvenire
i diritti umani sono anche i tuoi ea
volte tocca proprio a te difenderli
attivismo e un regalo bellissimo e un
superpotere alla portata di tutti noi